und wir sind hier im Deutschen Bundestag
gerade beim Start der vereinbarten
Debatte mit dem Thema Antisemitismus
bekämpfen erinnern heißt handeln und da
wird nun dein Ziel fazer die
Innenministerin als erste sprechen frau
Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren sehr
geehrter Herr deinhoff sehr geehrter
Herr Botschafter schön dass sie heute
dieser Debatte hier bei uns folgen heute
vor 84 Jahren setzten staatlich
organisierte Schlägertrupps jüdische
Gotteshäuser und Gebäude in Brand
tausende von Jüdinnen und Juden wurden
aus ihren Wohnungen gezerrt öffentlich
gequält und gedemütigt verhaftet getötet
es war der Beginn des größten massen-
und Völkermordes der Geschichte
diese barbarischen Taten fanden den ganz
Deutschland für alle sichtbar statt
unter dem geole von Anwohnern und
Nachbarn es gab bis auf Einzelfälle
keine Gegenwehr oder Unterstützung für
die jüdischen Nachbarn sie waren der
Gewalt schutzlos ausgeliefert Familien
die über Generationen geschätzte und
verdiente Bürgerinnen und Bürger waren
wurden ausgestoßen misshandelt ermordet
die Nacht des 9 November 1938 meine
Damen und Herren bleibt für immer eine
Nacht der Schande für unser Land
und es war der Beginn des größten
zivilbruchs die Erinnerung daran darf
niemals verblassen sie ist der Auftrag
dass sich so etwas niemals wiederholen
darf sie mahnt uns dass wir
Antisemitismus immer und mit aller Kraft
überall entgegentreten müssen
dieser Antisemitismus ist aber weder
1945 verschwunden noch ist er wie manche
behaupten erst durch Zuwanderung wieder
hierher gekommen nein er war immer da
und zwar nicht nur an den Rändern
sondern leider auch in unserer
Gesellschaft das zeigen uns Studien und
Erhebungen immer wieder sehr klar seit
Jahren verzeichnen wir einen
kontinuierlichen Anstieg antisemitischer
Straftaten oft sind es sogenannte
volksverhetzungsdelikte aber das aus
Worten Taten folgen können hat uns der
furchtbare Anschlag auf die Synagoge in
Halle sehr bitter vor Augen geführt und
ich will persönlich hinzufügen ich
schäme mich dafür dass in diesem Land
jüdische Kindertagesstätten und Schulen
noch immer polizeilich bewacht werden
müssen müssen alles dafür tun dass das
nicht mehr nötig ist meine Damen und
Herren
der antisemitische verschwörungswahn hat
während der corona-pandemie leider
Zulauf bekommen und antisemitische
Stereotype tauchen auch in vermeintlich
aufgeklärten Milieus immer wieder auf
das konnten wir gerade erst sehr bitter
auf der Dokumente in Kassel schmerzvoll
beobachten klar ist Antisemitismus
bedroht nicht allein Juden er bedroht
uns alle dieser Satz kann schnell wie
eine Plattitüde wirken aber er bringt es
auf den Punkt denn der Antisemitismus
ist ein Feind aller Jüdinnen und Juden
und zugleich der Feind aller
DemokratInnen und Demokraten in unserem
Land
die Bekämpfung von Antisemitismus muss
uns allen einen Anliegen sein denn
Antisemitismus ist niemals harmlos egal
ob er aus dem rechtsextremen dem
linksextremen oder dem islamistischen
Milieu stammt egal ob er an einem
Stammtisch oder in einer Moschee
verbreitet wird oder ob es sich um
Israel feindlichen Antisemitismus
handelt und hier möchte ich auch noch
mal daran gedenken weil es 50 Jahre her
ist der furchtbare Anschlag bei den
Olympischen Spielen 1972 dem wir ja
dieses Jahr auch gedacht haben und ich
denke dass das ganz wichtig ist auch
gerade dieses herausragend schlimmer
Ereignis für Jüdinnen und Juden an einem
solchen Tag in Erinnerung zu rufen
wir werden deshalb
meine Damen und Herren nicht müde jede
Form von Antisemitismus entschlossen zu
bekämpfen dabei gehören an erster Stelle
die politische Bildung die
Präventionsarbeit die von klein auf
passieren muss und das entschlossene
Handeln unserer Sicherheitsbehörden
natürlich eng verzahnt zusammen alle
diese drei Maßnahmen müssen immer
ineinander greifen und das ist auch der
Kern unseres Aktionsplans gegen
Rechtsextremismus zusätzlich erarbeiten
wir gerade die erste nationale Strategie
zur Bekämpfung von Antisemitismus und
dem Schutz jüdischen Lebens in
Deutschland diese Strategie wird ein
Werkzeug sein um Antisemitismus noch
besser und zielgerichteter zu bekämpfen
glücklicherweise gibt es in Deutschland
eine starke und lebendige
Zivilgesellschaft die mit Engagement und
Beharrlichkeit
Antisemitismus Arbeit auch unterstützt
all den engagierten Menschen gilt dafür
mein ausdrücklicher Dank weil sie
leisten wirklich hervorragendes in der
Bekämpfung dieses furchtbaren
ja wirklich judenfeindlichen Handels und
auch Hass und Hetze und diese Menschen
die das tun viele auch in ihrer Freizeit
und aber auch die NGOs die da unterwegs
sind müssen dafür auch eine verlässliche
Finanzierung und eine verlässliche
Unterstützung des Staates haben und
deshalb werden wir dieses Jahr noch das
demokratiefördergesetz auch auf dem Weg
bringen meine Damen und Herren
heute geht es zuallererst darum dass wir
den Millionen Opfern gedenken die uns
und ihrer erinnern und doch hört man
immer wieder das sei doch gar nicht mehr
nötig bei einem Drittel der Bevölkerung
ist das den Umfragen der Fall und das
erschüttert mich sehr und muss uns
wachrütteln dass wir was für das aktive
erinnern auch tun müssen
wer so argumentiert meine Damen und
Herren hat den Sinn und Zweck von
erinnern nämlich nicht verstanden es
geht darum so hat es Josef Schuster der
Vorsitzende des Zentralrats der Juden
gesagt dass auch die nachfolgenden
Generationen lernen wozu Menschen fähig
sind sie sollen verstehen warum in
unserem Staat die Achtung der
Menschenwürde und der Schutz von
Minderheiten so wichtig genommen werden
und meine Damen und Herren das darf ich
auch sagen wer in diesem Zusammenhang
von einem Vogelschiss oder einer
auschwitzkeule spricht verhöhnt die
Opfer der Shoa und das werden wir in
diesem Land nicht zulassen meine Damen
und Herren
wir werden nie vergessen und wir werden
alles tun damit das was so furchtbar in
diesem Land sich durch Menschen Ereignis
hat durch Menschen die das bewusst getan
haben dass so etwas nie wieder an
unserem Land passieren kann und dazu
gehört aktives Handeln des Rechtsstaates
aber auch eine herausragende
Erinnerungskultur vielen Dank für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
bundesinnenministerin Nancy Phaser hat
hier die Debatte eröffnet aufgrund des
besonderen Datums aber auch aufgrund
natürlich der
Handlungsnotwendigkeit die wir
angesichts der Zahlen haben unter die
Bedeutung sehen wir auch an der
Regierungsbank die fast vollständig ist
an diesem Tag Herr Präsident sehr
geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen
verehrte Gäste auf der Tribüne
die Erinnerung darf nicht enden unter
diesem Titel veranstalten eine
Bürgerinitiative und die jüdische
Gemeinde in meinem Wahlkreis in
Recklinghausen in diesem Minuten ein
gedenkonzert und eine Gedenkstunde in
der örtlichen Synagoge
es wird nicht die einzige Veranstaltung
hier in unserem Land heute sein
auch wenn ich nicht dabei sein kann die
Erinnerung darf nicht enden das ist an
dieser Stelle die Losung die wir heute
in dieser Debatte erneuern und den
Menschen zu rufen sollten das gilt
gerade wenn wir heute an die in der
Nacht vom 9 auf den 10 November 1938 von
SA und SS organisierten prognome
erinnern wir erinnern diese schreckliche
Nacht und an all das was auf sie folgte
aber in dem Titel unserer Debatte heute
hier im Deutschen Bundestag verbirgt
sich ein wichtiger Satz
erinnern heißt handeln und Handeln ist
wichtig denn es geht schlicht darum dass
jeder gleich wenn euch der Religion in
unserem Land sicher und frei leben darf
und das ist unser Auftrag
[Applaus]
und der Vizepräsident des jüdischen
Weltkongresses mal am Stern hat im
Vorfeld wie ich finde zu Recht darauf
hingewiesen dass wir nicht glauben
sollten dass gedenkdebatten so nützlich
und wichtig sie auch sind schon
ausreichend um uns vor zukünftige
Katastrophen zu bewahren allein ganz
sicher nicht blicken wir aktuell auf den
Antisemitismus in unserem Land dann gibt
es nichts schön zu reden er ist in der
Gesellschaft offener denn je präsent
Studien der Polizei in Umfragen zeigen
antisemitische Vorurteile Stereotype
kollektive Schuldzuweisung und
verschwörungsmythen sind leider fast
alltäglich
und ja deswegen braucht es übrigens auch
einen starken Verfassungsschutz
ein Amt an dem sich gut ablesen lässt
wie wichtig es ist weil sich die
Extremisten von allen Seiten so sehr
daran abarbeiten und wie wichtig es auch
ist nicht nur zu reden sondern als
Demokratie auch zu handeln schlicht
wehrhaft zu sein egal wo in unserem Land
es ist inakzeptabel dass sich jüdische
Menschen oft nicht mehr trauen ihre
Religion zu praktizieren und zu zeigen
das wirft einen Schatten auf unser
Gemeinwesen auf unsere freiheitlich hier
Demokratie denn ein Angriff auf
jüdisches Leben und das muss heute klar
sein ist immer auch ein Angriff auf uns
alle
ich begrüße daher dass die
Innenministerkonferenz auf ihrer Tagung
im Sommer den dringenden Handlungsbedarf
bei der Prävention von antisemitischer
und anti israelischer Hitze erkannt hat
am 30.11 treffen sich die Innenminister
erneut
und ich bin mir sicher es wird konkrete
Ansätze für eine notwendige
Weiterentwicklung von Maßnahmen geben
und diese werden auch beschlossen
aber wenn wir den Blick auf dieses Jahr
werfen so gehört in dieser Debatte auch
die Frage dazu wie es möglich sein
konnte dass die öffentlich geförderte
Dokumente fifty in Kassel zu einer der
schwersten Fälle von Antisemitismus in
den letzten Jahren mutieren konnte dass
dort judenfeindliche Kunstwerke offen
gezeigt wurden ist durch nichts zu
entschuldigen und es wäre heute eine
gute Gelegenheit wenn wir
fraktionsübergreifend als konsequent zu
diesen Vorkommnissen und einig darüber
zeigen dass es eine grundsätzliche
förderklausel des bundesbedarf die
vorsieht keine Veranstaltung mehr mit
Steuermitteln zu finanzieren die
Antisemitismus propagieren es sollte
eigentlich eine Selbstverständlichkeit
[Applaus]
und natürlich
haben wir in den letzten Jahren in
meinem Kampf gegen den
antisemitismus-parteiübergreifend gerade
auch bei der Schaffung von Strukturen
viel Gutes erreicht ich nenne eine neu
aufgestellte Antisemitismusforschung die
Einrichtung einer und länderkommission
sowie das Amt des
antisemitismusbeauftragten der
Bundesregierung und ich möchte in diesem
Zusammenhang heute ausdrücklich dem
Antisemitismus Beauftragten der
Bundesregierung dr Felix Klein für sein
großes und wichtiges Engagement
ausdrücklich Dank an herzlichen Dank
Weitergeben der Bericht heute im
Innenausschuss er war sehr eindrucksvoll
und wir brauchen
wenn wir es ernst meinen in der Zukunft
den 360 Grad Blick neben dem
Rechtsextremismus stellt das von
Islamisten verbreitete antisemitische
Gedankengut eine wachsende Gefahr für
das friedliche und tolerante
Zusammenleben in der Bundesrepublik da
auch im linken Spektrum
hat Antisemitismus Zulauf etwa im Zuge
von Kapitalismuskritik Antizionismus und
Antiimperialismus es ist auch eine
Schande wie viel antisemitische Hetze
Menschenverachtung und Verharmlosung des
Völkermordes an den europäischen Juden
auch von corona-leugnern und
Verschwörungstheoretikern verbreitet
wird das dürfen wir als Rechtsstaat
nicht dulden
und dies alles dies alles geschieht auch
immer mehr im Internet es ist
inakzeptabel wenn Betreiber sozialer
Netzwerke ihrer Pflicht nicht nachkommen
antisemitische Hassbotschaften innerhalb
der vorgesehenen Fristen die vorgegeben
sind zu löschen die Plattform das muss
ein Appell sein müssen hier konsequenter
vorgehen und ihrer unternehmerischen
Verantwortung gerecht werden
gleichzeitig müssen wir aber auch an
neuen Wegen arbeiten um anonyme Hetzer
im Netz besser zu identifizieren
daneben sind auch
länderübergreifende Konzepte
Justizbereich erforderlich die Bewertung
als antisemitisch motivierte Straftat
die verlangten fassende Kenntnis der
Tatumstände um den Kontext jeder
einzelnen Tat richtig beurteilen zu
können müssen außerdem im
Schulterschluss und das tun wir auch mit
den europäischen Partnern agieren mit
der im Oktober 2021 vorgelegten
Strategie zu Bekämpfung von
Antisemitismus und zu Förderung
jüdischen Lebens verpflichtet sich die
EU-Kommission dazu jüdisches Leben in
Europa und auch weltweit künftig zu
fördern meine Fraktion begrüßt diese
Strategie ausdrücklich aber auch der
Sport spielt eine große Rolle
im Kampf gegen Antisemitismus und
rechtsextremen Gedankengut trägt
insbesondere der Fußball eine
Riesenverantwortung und da war es ein
gutes Zeichen das für die Verdienste zum
Beispiel des Fußball-Bundesligisten
Borussia Dortmund im Kampf gegen den
Antisemitismus vor wenigen Tagen
Funktionäre des BVB ausgezeichnet wurden
was die wenigsten vielleicht wissen
wir müssen auch positiv vorangehen und
jüdisches Leben positiv in den
Vordergrund stellen und fördern und in
diesem Sinne sehe ich mit großem
Optimismus
insbesondere auch auf die jüngere
Generation
ich erlebe dort oft Offenheit Neugier
ehrliches Interesse das macht mir das
kann uns allen Hoffnung machen vielen
herzlichen Dank
die Rede des Bericht erstattet
für Antisemitismus ja Unionsfraktion und
wir sehen mittlerweile sind alle
Ministerinnen und Minister in dieser
Debatte anwesend und hören nun
lamiacador zu der Sprecherin für innen
und Religionspolitik der 9 November ist
für uns Deutsche ein sehr wichtiges
Datum und ich bin daher sehr froh dass
wir heute diese Debatte zum
Antisemitismus hier im Plenum gemeinsam
führen denn wir erinnern an das
antisemitische Grauen in unserem Land
vor 84 Jahren wurden über 1200 Synagogen
niedergebrannt unzählige Wohnungen
verwüstet und etwa 7.500 jüdische
Geschäfte zerstört Jüdinnen und Juden
wurden erschlagen niedergestochen oder
zu Tode gepökelt kurz darauf wurde im
ganzen deutschen Reich über 30.000
Männer verhaftet und in die
Konzentrationslager Sachsenhausen Dachau
und Buchenwald deportiert
alles Geschichte mitnichten auch 84
Jahre später müssen wir ausgerechnet in
Deutschland und es ist absolut
beschämend noch immer über Hass und
Hetze gegen Juden und Juden sprechen
sehr geehrte sehr geehrter Herr
Präsident meine Damen und Herren ich
möchte Ihnen von einer Begegnung
berichten meine muslimischen Kinder
besuchten beide die jüdischen
Kindergarten in Duisburg dieser liegt
aus Sicherheitsgründen am Ende eines
Innenhofs mit einer Pforte aus
Panzerglas hinter der ein
Sicherheitsmann sitzt und den
Sicherheitszaun Sam Grundstück bewacht
ich wollte eines unserer Kinder an einem
Nachmittag ab und begleitete es Hand in
Hand aus dem Kindergarten plötzlich rief
ein älterer Mann von oben von seinem
Balkon euch hätte man alle vergasen
müssen
ich legte mich lautstark mit ihm an und
versuchte an meinem erschrockenen Kind
zu erklären dass der Herr voller
Abneigung wäre es aber nicht an uns
liege ich gebe zu dass ich nach dem
Schlagabtausch still aber aufgewühlt vor
mir her dachte was hätte er gedacht wenn
er gewusst hätte dass ich Muslimen und
nicht Jüdin bin
Wut und Frustration erfüllten mich diese
Szene die ich nicht vergessen kann zeigt
dass Antisemitismus keine Jüdinnen und
Juden benötigt um zu funktionieren es
kann jede und jeden treffen jedes Mal
wenn eine Jüdin oder ein Jude
angegriffen wird ist es als würden wir
selbst angegriffen und so sehe ich es
Menschenfeindlichkeit macht nämlich von
niemandem Halt am Ende trifft es die
Demokratie als Ganzes es ist daher
inakzeptabel das Jüdinnen und Juden im
Jahr 2022 in Deutschland Angst haben
müssen in der Öffentlichkeit religiöse
Symbole zu tragen die Schule zu besuchen
oder in einer jüdische Kultureinrichtung
zu gehen
insbesondere seit Beginn der
corona-pandemie verzeichnen wir eine
Ausbreitung des Antisemitismus durch
impfgegnerinnen und Impfgegner
sogenannten spaziergänger:innen
querdenker:innen flankiert von den
altbekannten rechtsextremistischen
islamistischen und auch
linksextremistischen Strömungen mit
ihren antisemitischen Denkmustern und
Verschwörungsideologien wird der Hass in
der Mitte in die Mitte der Gesellschaft
gespült die steigenden Zahlen zur
politisch motivierten Kriminalität und
die Hasskriminalität gegen Jüdinnen und
Juden die auch in der digitalen Realität
tobt unterstreichen den Handlungsbedarf
Bekämpfung von Antisemitismus ist
Kernaufgabe einer Bundesregierung die
ihre Bürgerinnen und Bürger schützt die
den gesellschaftlichen Zusammenhalt und
die Resilienz der Demokratie stärkt und
Sicherheit gewährleistet
wir verzeichnen zwar Erfolge bei der
Sichtbarmachung jüdischen Lebens und
beim empowerment jüdischer Gemeinden in
Deutschland das heißt aber nicht dass
ich noch viel zu tun wäre um jüdisches
Leben weiter zu stärken ist die
Errichtung einer Stelle zu Erforschung
jüdische Lebensrealitäten ein wichtiger
Schritt und daher werden wir einen
nationale Strategie zu Bekämpfung von
Antisemitismus vorliegen deren
Notwendigkeit auch heute dr klein im
Innenausschuss betont hatte bei der
Prävention müssen wir schon früh
anfangen Lehrinhalte und Exkursionen mit
sehr guter Vor- und Nachbereitung müssen
aus meiner Sicht verpflichtend werden
Pädagogen und Pädagogen Erzieherinnen
und Erzieher müssen besser geschult
werden wer Diskriminierungen unserer
Gesellschaft verkämmt wer bei Protesten
jeglicher Couleur mitmarschiert und
dabei antisemitischen Bekundungen duldet
ist eine Gefahr für unser Land und
dieser Gefahr müssen und werden sich die
demokratischen Fraktionen in diesem Haus
gemeinsam entgegenstellen vielen Dank
vielen Dank Frau Kolleginnen
das nächste Wort die Kollegin Beatrix
von Storch afd-fraktion
herr Präsident meine Damen und Herren
wer im Jahr 22 über Antisemitismus redet
kann von der gefährlichsten
antisemitischen Bewegung in Westeuropa
nicht schweigen der bds-bewegung die hat
eine Schlüsselfunktion sie ist das
dreckige Bindeglied zwischen dem linken
und muslimischen Antisemitismus von
Intellektuellen Künstlern Aktivisten von
Greta Thunberg und Claudia Roth zum
gewaltbereiten muslimischen
Antisemitismus von Hisbollah und Hamas
der Titel dieser Aussprache heißt
erinnern und handeln also erinnern wir
uns der Bundestag hat eine Resolution
zur BDS verabschiedet und eine gegen
Antisemitismus alles ohne jede messbare
Wirkung die
antisemitismus-resolution fordert
ausländerrechtliche Konsequenzen also
Abschiebung bei Antisemitismus das ist
nicht ein einziges Mal passiert und die
BDS Resolution sagt dass die
bds-bewegung keine Räume mehr bekommt
und keine finanziellen Mittel das lehnt
kulturstaatsministerin Roth in ihrer
abstimmungserklärung vom 17 mai 2019
expressis verbis ab solange sich
Deutschland also eine solche
kulturstaatsministerin leistet ist der
Kampf gegen Antisemitismus eine Fachs
bestenfalls eine Phase eigentlich eher
eine Verhöhnung der Opfer kommen wir zum
Handeln wenn man etwas gegen den
Judenhass erreichen will sollte man sich
das Land angucken das als einziges in
dem sich die Juden als einziges seit
Merkels flüchtlingskrise 2015 sicherer
fühlen weniger angegriffen fühlen als
vor Merkels flüchtlingskrise und das ist
Ungarn die Europäische Union hat in
ihrer hatten großen Erhebung 2018 16.000
Juden in Westeuropa befragt das Ergebnis
ist eindeutig der Anteil der Juden die
zum Beispiel Angst vor gewaltsamen
Angriffen haben wo denn Ungarn zwischen
2012 und 2018 auf unter 30 Prozent
halbiert in Deutschland ist im selben
Zeitraum diese Quote auf über 60 Prozent
gestiegen Angst bei Juden vor
Übergriffen über 60 Prozent nach einer
Erhebung der Europäischen Union der
Anteil der Juden die tatsächlich
Opfer von Übergriffen wurden ist in
Ungarn auf 17 Prozent zurückgegangen und
in Deutschland um etwa ein Drittel auf
knapp 30 Prozent gestiegen knapp 30%
aller Juden in Deutschland
Opfer von Angriff Rabbiner Slomo köves
sagte das Gute Beispiel Ungarn sollte
man auf die ganze EU anwenden Merkels
bundland ist für Juden immer
gefährlicher und Orbans dezidiert
katholisches Ungarn ist für Jugend immer
sicherer oder wie im Dezember 2017 die
linksliberale israelische Zeitung Haras
titelte ich zitiere wörtlich
angrys keeping juice safe bei keeping
Muslims out Zitat Ende
und statt Hans-Georg Maaßen zu
verleumden sollten sich unsere Lima
unsere linken klima-terroristen um Luisa
Neubauer dem Antisemitismus in ihrer
klimasektor widmen von Hamburg bis nach
Gaza Klima in tifada das war der
Schlachtruf mehr muss man gar nicht
wissen diese grünen Klima Spinner sind
ideologisch verloren extremistisch und
auch antisemitisch wir sollten die alle
irgendwo hinkleben an irgendeinen hohlen
Baumstumpf wo sie niemanden stören und
keinen mehr töten können erinnern und
Handeln steht über dieser Debatte heute
sie sind hier in der Regierung und
könnten handeln aber sie werden wieder
nichts tun wenn die AFD regiert werden
wir Judenhasser und Islamisten
abschieben und keine neuen mehr
hereinlassen werden
haschmuseen schließen bds-
[Applaus]
nicht so Rednern ist die Kollegin in der
Torte der FDP-Fraktion
herr Präsident sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren und die ganze Straße sah zu so
schilderte Josef Schuster heute bei
einer Gedenkveranstaltung auf Einladung
des Bundespräsidenten Gedanken von
deutschen Staatsbürgern jüdischen
Glaubens die die reichspo diese
programmnacht erlebt haben diese Tage
der Ermordung Erniedrigung von Menschen
in unserem Land was uns mit Scham und
Trauer erfüllen muss und es ist ein
großes Geschenk für unser Land und
Ausdruck eines großen
vertrauensvorschusses das wieder
Jüdinnen und Juden in unserem Land leben
und uns am Land diesen
Vertrauensvorschuss gegeben haben liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
umso
umso beschämender ist es denn erinnern
heißt handeln und da geht es auch um die
Sicherheit von Jüdinnen und Juden heute
in unserem Land das verschiedene Akteure
heute sich nicht verkneifen können
diesen historischen Tag zu benutzen für
andere politische Anliegen ich will
jetzt nicht über die Kundgebungen die es
auch heute abend leider in Berlin geben
wird
an denen wahrscheinlich wieder auch
Israel bezogene Antisemitismus Ausdruck
findet stattfinden sondern nur
beispielhaft etwas anderes herausgreifen
was ich mir nach dem
dokumenta-skandal der einer mit Ansage
und Wegbereitern war nicht hätte
vorstellen können dass das
Goethe-Institut in Tel Aviv zum Beispiel
vorhatte am heutigen Tag ernsthaft
gemeinsam mit der
Rosa-Luxemburg-Stiftung eine
Veranstaltung unter dem Motto den
Schmerz der anderen verstehen über die
Nachbar zu veranstalten gefördert mit
öffentlichen Geldern das zeigt wie hilft
das Problem sitzt und wie ernsthaft wir
uns damit auseinandersetzen müssen
Liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen das
Antisemitismus kein neues Thema ist dass
er ein beschämender Teil des Alltags in
unserem Land ist das ist für uns frei
Demokraten nicht neu und es ist nicht
überraschend allein ist tröstet nicht
das beruhigt nicht denn es geht um eine
gemeinsame große Verantwortung für ein
hohes Gut nämlich dafür dass jüdisches
Leben bei uns sicher frei und
selbstbestimmt stattfinden kann und vor
allem das Jüdinnen und Juden selbst
darauf vertrauen und da darf es nicht
von der Stärke einer synagogentür
abhängen wie in Halle ob Jüdinnen und
Juden sich sicher fühlen können
und der notwendige Polizeischutz der
eben schon erwähnt wurde der ist ebenso
notwendig wie es traurig ist dass er
notwendig ist und deshalb ist es nicht
hinreichend dass wir ihn gewährleisten
wir müssen die gesellschaftlichen Türen
vor Antisemitismus fest verschließen vor
menschenverachtenden Gedankengut damit
es oft realen Türen nicht ankommt
auffällig am Antisemitismus ist dass er
regelmäßig Hand in Hand mit
verschwörungserzählungen geht und dass
er uns auch in verschiedenen Debatten
außenpolitischen wirtschaftspolitischen
und kulturpolitischen begegnet ist ein
hilfloser Reflex auf die Komplexität
moderner Gesellschaften und ihrer
Herausforderungen und es gilt diesen
menschenverachtenden Gedankengut immer
und überall klar entgegenzutreten egal
ob es auch vermeintlich geschmeidig
gefällig harmlos entgegenkommt denn klar
ist jeder Erscheinungsform von
Antisemitismus ist inakzeptabel
und weil die Erinnerungskultur die wir
uns in unserem Land erarbeitet haben
nämlich was in liberalen Demokratien
übrigens gerade nicht die Normalität
sondern etwas sehr Besonderes und
kostbares ist dass man nämlich eine
historische Tatsache auch moralisch
eindeutig bewertet und nicht
verschiedene Meinungen darüber hat
sondern ein klaren Konsens darüber über
die Singularität des
menschheitsverbrechens der Shoa gerade
deshalb muss es uns besorgen dass es
neue Tendenzen der Relativierung und der
Verharmlosung gibt
die weil diese Erinnerungskultur so
kostbar ist und weil sich die
Erinnerungskultur weiterentwickeln muss
mit unserer Gesellschaft ohne diese
Verantwortung zu verlieren müssen uns
Apartheid zum Kolonialismus
Analogien auch besorgen denn es geht
darf nicht zu einer Verharmlosung kommen
nicht zu einer Relativierung
denn dort sind regelmäßig
Doppelstandards Dämonisierung und
Delegitimierung des Staates Israel nicht
weit die Shoah ist singulär ihre
Dimension sie ist schwerlich in Sprache
zu fassen und doch müssen wir sie
benennen weil wir sie nicht beschweigen
dürfen
der glaubt die Glaubwürdigkeit des
Kampfes gegen Antisemitismus die hängt
davon ab das ist kein Unterschied macht
aus welcher Ecke Antisemitismus kommt
wir brauchen eine ganzheitliche
Strategie gegen Antisemitismus über die
werden wir aber in den nächsten Wochen
auch ausführlicher sprechen können und
deshalb denke ich geht es jetzt darum
dass wir in eine Situation kommen in der
mehr Raum ist als es heute war denn
heute beschäftigt und belastet uns denke
ich eher der starke der unerträglich
starke Antisemitismus dass wir auch über
die Vielfalt jüdischen Lebens und die
Vielfalt jüdischer Kultur in unserem
Land sprechen können ich finde das wäre
ein gutes Ziel für zukünftige Debatten
dass man seine Redezeit darauf verwenden
kann auf diese Vielfalt jüdischer Kultur
und jüdischen Lebens in Deutschland
vielen Dank
lindert heute Berg sagt das jüdisches
Leben frei und sicher stattfinden soll
wenn man sich aber zum Beispiel den
Jahresbericht des Bundesverbands der
Recherche und Informationsstellen
Antisemitismus RIAS anschaut dann findet
das eben nicht statt
2738 strafbare und nicht strafbare
Vorfälle wurden gemeldet
Frau Präsident sehr geehrte Kolleginnen
und Kollegen sehr geehrte Gäste es war
und bleibt richtig dass wir im Bundestag
an den 9 November
1938 die Reichspogromnacht erinnern
danach beschlossen die Nazis den
systematischen Mord an allen Juden und
Juden und es folgte ein unsägliches
Menschheitsverbrechen
deshalb sage ich auch wer diese
furchtbare Zeit und diese Vorgänge als
Vogelschiss deutscher Geschichte
verharmlost macht sich nachträglich
mitschuldig
der nötige Rückblick ersetzt aber nicht
den aktuellen draufblick und die
pünktliche Debatte im Bundestag darf
nicht das alltägliche Dilemma ausblenden
Antisemitismus ist präsent und bedroht
Jüdinnen und Juden hierzulande weil sie
Jüdinnen und Juden sind das ist wieder
den Anspruch des Grundgesetzes aber es
ist vor allen Dingen auch eine Gefahr
für Leib und Leben und deshalb nicht
hinnehmbar
einmal im Quartal frage ich die
Bundesregierung wie viele Straf- und
Gewalttaten sie mit antisemitischen
Hintergrund registriert hat die Zahlen
sind hoch und steigend das ist schlimm
zugleich stapeln Sie tief denn
Antisemitismus erfahren Jüdinnen und
Juden auch im Alltag viele Wagen es
bereits nicht mehr sich öffentlich
jüdisch zu bekennen und deshalb reicht
es nicht an 1938 und die Nazizeit zu
erinnern der Bundestag die Politik die
Gesellschaft müssen sich verstärkt gegen
aktuellen Antisemitismus engagieren
das kontra zum Antisemitismus bedarf
aber eines pro zum jüdischen Leben und
das beginnt in der Schulzeit
Schülerinnen und Schüler erfahren als zu
oft im Unterricht erstmals etwas über
Juden wenn es um den Holocaust geht
danach sind Juden dann vor allen Dingen
Opfer über jüdische Kultur jüdisches
Leben in der Geschichte und in unserer
Gesellschaft erfahren sie kaum etwas und
das muss ich dringend ändern dem
Nobelpreisträger die Künstlerinnen und
Künstler die erfolgreichen Sportler
überhaupt Jüdinnen und Juden gehören in
die Lehrpläne und in das alltägliche
Leben
und auch ein aktuelles Thema natürlich
sind die christlichen Feiertage aus
unserem Jahreskalender nicht wegzudenken
was ist eigentlich mit jüdischen
Feiertagen oder wenigstens dem Respekt
vor der Religionsausübung sei es bei der
Terminierung von Prüfung oder bei der
Organisation in den Hochschulen oder im
Arbeitsleben auch hier ist noch viel
handlungs
ein letzter Punkt es wurde schon erwähnt
wir haben heute Vormittag im
Innenausschuss mit dem Beauftragten für
jüdisches Leben und zur Bekämpfung des
Antisemitismus über die im Moment in
Entwicklung befindliche nationale
Strategie zur Bekämpfung des
Antisemitismus gesprochen ich hoffe sehr
die Bundesregierung ist ja hier nahezu
vollständig vertreten dass sie Ende des
Monats diese Strategie entsprechend
verabschieden und dass wir uns gemeinsam
der Umsetzung derselben und der
Verbreitung bis in die letzte Kommune
annehmen und uns entsprechend engagieren
ich danke Ihnen
vielen Dank Frau Kollegin Frau
und hier gab es nicken
besonders der Wunsch von Petra Pau kam
der Krise ist der nächste Redner
stellvertretender Fraktionsvorsitzender
der SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident Kolleginnen
und Kollegen sehr geehrter Herr
Botschafter der heutigen 9 November ist
kein normaler Tag es ist ein Tag zum
Innehalten zum Erinnern an dem wir den
Blick in die Vergangenheit richten
müssen denn der 9 November wird zu Recht
als Schicksalstag der deutschen
bezeichnet an diesem Tag nahmen viele
Schicksale in diesem Land in den letzten
Jahrzehnten eine unerwartete
hoffnungsvolle aber auch grausame
Wendung ein am 9 November 1989 haben
viele in der ehemaligen DDR neue
Hoffnung geschöpft auf eine Zukunft mit
mehr Freiheit und mehr Möglichkeiten für
sich und ihre Familien und es war ein
guter Tag für unser heute wieder
vereinigtes Land der 9 November 1938 war
aber das genaue Gegenteil in
nationalsozialistischen Deutschland
kommt es zu organisierten Übergriffen
gegen Jüdinnen und Juden jüdische Läden
Institutionen werden zerstört Synagogen
brennen werden verwüstet bei mir im
Sauerland unter anderem in Arnsberg
Meschede und Brilon Polizei und
Feuerwehr hatten damals die Weisung
nicht einzugreifen wollten es oftmals
auch gar nicht Bürgerinnen und Bürgern
Nachbarn machten aktiv mit oder schauten
Weg in dieser Nacht haben jüdische
Mitbürgerinnen und Mitbürger vielleicht
endgültig erkannt dieser Terrorstaat hat
sich gegen sie entschieden er hat über
ihr Schicksal befunden und es für nicht
schützenswert ja nicht lebenswert
erachtet und dieser Hass gegen unsere
jüdischen Mitbürger mündete in dem
schrecklichsten Zivilisationsbruch
unserer Geschichte die
Menschheitsverbrechen der Showa und ich
sage ganz deutlich für unsere
Verantwortung vor der Geschichte gibt es
keinen Schlussstrich der 9 November ist
hier für Mahnung und Warnung an uns alle
zugleich
der Kampf gegen Antisemitismus und die
Förderung jüdischen Lebens ist unsere
gemeinsame Aufgabe und die Aufgabe aller
Demokraten hier im Haus denn das
vergangene Jahr hat es uns doch gezeigt
jüdisches Leben gehört seit 1700 Jahren
zu unserem Land zu unserer Geschichte
und es ist ein Teil von uns und gerade
deshalb sind wir alle verpflichtet gegen
Judenhass und Judenfeindschaft
aufzustehen und zu handeln das ist die
Lehre die wir aus der Geschichte ziehen
müssen und gerade die jüngere Generation
steht hier in der Verantwortung gerade
in einer Zeit wo wir uns die Frage
stellen müssen wie Erinnerungskultur
zukünftig möglich ist wenn die
Zeitzeugen nicht mehr unter uns sind und
Kolleginnen und Kollegen erheben wir
deshalb gemeinsam unsere Stimme gegen
jede Form des Antisemitismus egal in
welchem Gewand er daherkommt und egal
wie er sich in der Neuzeit ausbreitet
sei es mit verschwörungstheoretischen
Vorurteilen während der Finanzkrise
während der corona-pandemie wo es
abscheulichste Vergleiche gerade mit
Anne Frank gegeben hat gerade in diese
Zeiten wo hast und Hetze einer lauten
Minderheit zuzunehmen scheiden gerade in
diesen Zeiten sind wir gemeinsam
gefordert klären wir darum auf wo
verschwörungserzählungen und
Diffamierung jüdische Menschen treffen
stehen wir gemeinsam auf und geben wir
dem Antisemitismus in der Mitte unsere
Gesellschaft keinen Platz vielen Dank
Wiese war das hat wie auch andere schon
zuvor auch den Botschafter des Staates
Israel hier besonders gegrüßt Ron Poser
schaut hier auch zu genauso wie der
Vizepräsident des Zentralrats der Juden
am Markt der Einwohner Kollegen es ist
eine gute Entscheidung gewesen dass wir
im heutigen Tage hier im Hohen Hause
der Frage nachgehen was wir gegen
Antisemitismus in Deutschland tun können
der Vorsitzende der Zentralrats der
Juden in Deutschland hat ein klein wenig
gemahnt und hat gesagt der 9 November
ist in der deutschen Geschichte eben mit
vielen Facetten versehen ich glaube die
die mich am meisten zum Nachdenken
bringen bringt ist eben doch das Datum
des 9 November 1938 weil das was dort
geschehen ist sowas in der Folge
geschehen ist eine so unbeschreibliche
Zivilisationsbruch gewesen ist dass man
als junger und auch als erwachsener
Mensch immer noch damit zu kämpfen hat
dass wirklich zu verstehen und
nachzuvollziehen wir denken an die
vielen Opfer aber wir denken auch an
diejenigen die sich in der Folge des 9
November 38
schuldig gemacht haben entweder weil sie
weggesehen haben weil sie verweigert
haben die Hilfe gegenüber jüdischen
Mitbürgerinnen und Mitbürgern die von
der SA und vom Mob verprügelt worden
sind die deportiert und umgebracht
worden sind und die sich bereichert
haben an dem Vermögen ihre jüdischen
Mitbürgerinnen und Mitbürger und die zum
Teil bis weit in die Nachkriegszeit zu
ihrem Tode nicht verstanden haben dass
das Unrecht war sich zu bereichern an
dem an dem Vermögen das den Juden
weggenommen worden war und das ist auch
ein Thema an das ich heute denke ich
komme aus einem
Wahlkreis in dem es eine gebärgische
Land Sodingen Remscheid Wuppertal in dem
es eine starke jüdische Gemeinde gibt
die ist in den 90er Jahren deutlich
gewachsen als auch als Ergebnis des
Falls das Eisernen Vorhangs und es hat
dann in meiner Heimatstadt Wuppertal ein
Ereignis gegeben an dem der heutige
Botschafter des Staates Israel in
Deutschland von brosow persönlichen
Anteil hatte es wurde in Wuppertal eine
neue Synagoge gebaut und zwar auf dem
Grunde Boden den die evangelische Kirche
die gemarkerkirche in Wuppertal dort wo
die Barmer Synode getagt hat die das
letzte Aufbäumen der Christen gegen den
Nationalsozialismus 1935 oder eines der
großen letzten aufbäumung diese
Kirchengemeinde hat für einen
symbolischen Markt der jüdischen
Gemeinde ein Grundstück verkauft und ist
die neue Synagoge dort errichtet worden
und ronproso hat damals als junger
Diplomat daran maßgeblichen Anteil
gehabt dass die dann von den Präsidenten
kazav und
rau-obertaler Bürger eingeweiht wurde
ich erinnere aber auch daran dass im
Jahr 2014
drei junge Menschen Jugendliche
Brian Brandanschlag versucht haben zu
verüben auf diese Synagoge gott sei Dank
ist der Brandsatz nicht gezündet aber
wenn er gezündet wäre wäre diese
Synagoge erheblich beschädigt oder gar
ein Brand geraten worden und dann gab es
ein Gerichtsurteil und dann haben die
jungen Menschen in diesem kriegsurteil
gesagt sie wollten mit ihrer Aktion ja
nur gegen die israelische Politik gegen
die Palästinenser demonstrieren
bemerke den Fehler der Angriff auf ein
jüdisches Gotteshaus in Deutschland wird
gerechtfertigt mit einem Protest gegen
israelische Politik und es hat die
Richter zu einem vergleichsweise milden
Strafmaß verleitet und das hat weltweit
international aufzählen erregt und bis
heute zu wirkt das in der jüdischen
Gemeinde in Wuppertal nach wir hatten
dann 192021 die Situation
dass unsere Freunde aus der Patenstadt
von Solingen nestiona in der Stadt waren
es war die fahndete Staates Israel vor
dem Rathaus in Solingen gehisst auch
über Nacht und dann wurde diese Fahne in
der Nacht
1921/21 im Frühsommer in Brand gesetzt
wir haben daraus den Schluss gezogen
dass wir einmal im Jahr nämlich immer
dann wenn unsere Freunde aus nestione an
Solingen da sind einen Tag machen an dem
wir das jüdische Leben in Solingen
sichtbar machen indem wir uns vor dem
Rathaus versammeln eine Kipper tragen
und damit zeigen dass man als Mensch in
Deutschland jüdischen Glaubens den
Schutz aller anderen verdient und
genießt wenn man sich zu seinem Glauben
bekennt und seinen Glauben ausübt aber
das ist nach wie vor in Deutschland
passiert das israelische Fahnen
angezündet werden ist ein erschreckendes
Zeichen und mahnt uns weiter aktiv gegen
Antisemitismus zu kämpfen
zum Schluss möchte ich noch einen Satz
sagen vielleicht auch als Vizepräsident
der deutsche gesellschaftlichen
Gesellschaft was wir vielleicht auch
noch tun können um das Verständnis der
Deutschen für die Politik und für das
Leben in Israel zu verbessern ich glaube
dass wir noch viele Wege beschreiten
können und beschreiten müssen um die
Deutschen und die Bürger Israels näher
zueinander zu bringen die Jugend den
Austausch der Jugend zu fördern die
Zusammenarbeit der Wissenschaft die
Zusammenarbeit der Wirtschaft
weiterzuentwickeln und zu fördern damit
wir dem deutsch-jüdischen Verhältnis
eine entsprechende neue zusätzliche
Dimension verleihen die uns vielleicht
hilft Antisemitismus auch in Deutschland
ein für allemal zu überwinden herzlichen
Jürgen hart war das für die
Unionsfraktion und nun spricht die
kulturstaatsministerin Claudia Roth
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen sehr geehrter
Ron rosa
Charlotte Knobloch deren 90 Geburtstag
wir vor wenigen Tagen gefeiert haben hat
nie vergessen was sie am 9 November
1938 in München erleben musste sie hat
es nie vergessen können niemand könnte
das wer erlebt das in wenigen Tagen
alles was dem eigenen Leben Gewissheit
und Vertrauen gehabt zerstört wird der
wird das sein Leben lang nie vergessen
wer den 9 November
1938 erlebt hat für den kann nie wieder
niemals nur ein leeres Wort bleiben sagt
Charlotte Knobloch kein leeres Wort
nicht im Land der Täter nicht in dem
Land das Charlotte Knobloch das Fritz
Bauer und mit ihnen viele Jüdinnen und
Juden trotz der Show trotz der
unermesslichen Schuld dieses Land alles
mit aufgebaut haben
wir sind heute versammelt um zu bekennen
voll Scham zu bekennen jüdisches Leben
ist in Deutschland noch immer bedroht
Antisemitismus existiert noch immer in
diesem Land deswegen heißt erinnern an
den 9 November auch immer kämpfen für
die Demokratie und gegen Antisemitismus
und diese Erinnerung
diese Erinnerung ist keine Pflicht und
keine Bußübung keine ich zitiere
dämliche
bewältigungspolitik wie Sie Björn höcke
für die AFD bezeichnet
diese Erinnerung ist ein Kampf auch
gegen die Feinde der Demokratie die
Erinnerung an den 9 November an den
Opfer des an die Opfer des Terrors an
das was diesem Tag vorausging und an die
Konsequenzen die dieser
Zivilisationsbruch hatte diese
Erinnerung ist ein Dienst an uns selber
an uns allen der 9 November sagt
Charlotte Knobloch war das Tor nach
Auschwitz es ist die Wahrheit und diese
Wahrheit sie ist uns zuzumuten sie
erinnert uns daran dass wir nicht
vergessen dürfen dass das Gift des
Hasses langsam wirkte und wirkt dass auf
Verleumdung Diskriminierung folgte auf
Ausgrenzung Verfolgung und am Ende
Zerstörung und Vernichtung stand Hass
Missgunst und Ausgrenzung bedeuten
Verrat an der Demokratie
über 3000 Fälle antisemitischer
Straftaten die das
Bundesinnenministerium im vergangenen
Jahr feststellte sind über 3000 zu viel
die Vielfalt die Vielzahl an
judenfeindlichen Straftaten und ja auch
der schlimme Vorfall bei der Dokumenta
sind nicht nur ein Angriff auf jüdisches
Leben in unserem Land sondern auch ein
Angriff auf unser Zusammenleben auf das
wir alle und sind auch eine riesengroße
deswegen eine riesengroße
Herausforderung für die Politik in
unserem Land
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen unser
Land hat am 9 November 1938 seine Würde
verloren es hat Jahre und Jahrzehnte
gedauert um wieder aufgenommen zu werden
in den Kreis der zivilisierten Länder
ganz zu allererst verdanken wir dies
Israel und unseren jüdischen Mitbürgern
und Mitbürgerinnen die Freundschaft mit
Israel die Zusammenarbeit und der Kampf
gegen
Antisemitismus sind unverrückbarer Teil
der deutschen Staatsräson und sie sind
konstitutiv für unsere Demokratie und
für die Bundesrepublik Deutschland
und es war der Kampf gegen das Vergessen
der dieses Land der unsere Gesellschaft
verfasst hat ich glaube man kann sagen
so sind wir zu einer freien und
demokratischen Gesellschaft geworden und
wir sind nicht am Ende der Geschichte
angekommen unser Leben in Freiheit und
Demokratie ist keine
Selbstverständlichkeit wer sich erinnern
kann weiß das und wer daran erinnert
weiß das auch wir werden unsere Freiheit
und Demokratie verteidigen müssen sagt
Charlotte Knobloch recht hat sie
vielen Dank Frau Claudia Roth änderte
hier mit einem Zitat in der Debatte
Antisemitismus bekämpfen erinnern statt
Handeln angesichts des 84
jahrestags der Reichsprogromnacht in
Deutschland Mark Jong der
kulturpolitische Sprecher der
afd-fraktion ist der nächste Redner
Präsident meine Damen und Herren am
heutigen 9 November dem deutschen
Schicksalstag im Guten wie im Bösen zur
Bekämpfung des Antisemitismus aufzurufen
ist angemessen und geboten erinnern
heißt handeln wie es im heutigen Titel
heißt das stimmt in diesem Kurzschluss
aber leider nicht die deutsche
Erinnerungskultur macht zunehmend den
Eindruck einer kompensatorischen
Veranstaltung viel symbolischer Aufwand
und pathetische Worte die immer öfter
aber nur kaschieren das ist einen
eklatanten Mangel an Handlungen gegen
den wachsenden Antisemitismus gibt
schlimmer noch während immer neue
Mahnmale und Gedenkorte zu den
NS-Verbrechen errichtet werden sorgt
Ihre aktuelle Politik zugleich dafür
dass sich Juden wieder unsicher und
bedroht fühlen in Deutschland dass sie
an Auswanderung denken müssen in
Frankreich ist es längst so weit das ist
doch die peinliche Wahrheit
sie sorgen dafür indem sie weiter die
Massenmigration aus einem Kulturkreis
fördern nämlich den islamischen in dem
nachweislich der größte Judenhass
weltweit grassiert die Umfragen und
Statistiken sind hier eindeutig fragen
sie bitte jüdische Mitbürger in welchen
Stadtvierteln in Berlin oder analog in
Paris oder anderswo in Europa sie haben
allerwenigsten mit einer Kippa spazieren
gehen würden und sie werden eine
eindeutige Antwort erhalten es sind
nicht die Viertel mit der angeblich so
rassistischen Einheimischen
Mehrheitsbevölkerung natürlich gibt es
Antisemitismus überall aber hören Sie
endlich auf die Gesellschaft pauschal
anzubräunen und benennen sie Ross und
Reiter wenn sie von Antisemitismus
sprechen
und Frau Feser sie haben heute den
Islamismus benannt aber ihre generelle
Blindheit auf dem islamistischen Auge
kann unserem Land und speziell den Juden
in Deutschland noch teuer zu stehen
kommen wenn Sie hier nicht Umsteuern und
sie fördern ja auch ganz systematisch
den Antisemitismus auf der ideologischen
Ebene die Dokumente 15 hat mit ihren
Skandalen hat es ans Licht gebracht der
Postkolonialismus dem
kulturstaatsministerin Roth genauso
huldigt wie ihre Vorgängerin im Amt
Monika Grütters CDU ist nicht nur eine
Ideologie des Ressentiments gegenüber
dem Westen und allen weißen es ist auch
eine Ideologie des ti der tief
verwurzelten Judenfeindschaft Edward
Said Gründervater des boskolonialismus
palästinensischer Herkunft hat sein
wissenschaftliches Werk explizit in den
Kontext seines politischen Engagements
gegen Israel gestellt ich zitiere hier
die FAZ vom September die Saat dieses
Hasses ist heute breit aufgegangen hat
den akademischen Diskurs zuerst
vergiftet und sie vergiftet jetzt
zunehmend auch unsere Kultur und
Erinnerungspolitik und solange sie eine
Ideologie idel und finanziell fördern
deren sumpfgewächs die Israel
boykottbewegung BDS ist eine
existenzielle Bedrohung für Juden in
aller Welt ist ihr erinnern kein handeln
sondern es tut mir leid das sagen zu
müssen zu einem großen Teil Heuchelei
und hören Sie bitte auf Frau Roth mit
ihren wirklich haltlosen Anschuldigungen
in unsere Richtung wenn eine Politik für
die Juden für die Sicherheit der Juden
in Deutschland sorgen würde dann ist das
die Politik der AFD vielen Dank
vielen Dank nächster Rednerin ist die
Kollegin an Nico Glogowski Merten
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen fertig Gäste
auf der Tribüne
es sind eigentlich so manche Worte an
diesem Pult die das Erinnern vergiften
dieser Satz sei mir gestattet jüdisches
Leben gehört zu Deutschland
das gilt für die Vergangenheit genauso
wie für die Zukunft
die
novemberprogramme und das was daraus
folgte sind jedoch in unserer
kollektives Gedächtnis als grauenhafte
Verbrechen eingebrannt jüdisches Leben
sollte in Deutschland komplett
vernichtet werden
die Aufarbeitung der Vergangenheit ist
mitnichten eine Selbstverständlichkeit
Erinnerungskultur braucht Raum sie
braucht Orte innerhalb derer sie sich
entfalten kann sie braucht Mut und
Zuversicht
in meinem Heimatwahlkreis Braunschweig
hatte ich vor kurzem das Glück einen
dieser Orte das Braunschweiger
Landesmuseum hinter aegidien an welchem
wir die Erinnerungskultur für jüdisches
Leben in Deutschland pflegen
dokumentieren und archivieren zu
besuchen die Sammlung gehört die
Sammlung von Objekten des religiösen
Gebrauchs gehört zu den historisch
bedeutendsten in Deutschland sie ist ein
Zusammenspiel von Erinnerung von
Dokumentation und von Aufarbeitung
letzteres ist vor allem dann unabdingbar
wenn es um die Schaffung von
Perspektiven für die Gegenwart aber auch
für die Zukunft jüdischen Lebens geht
die historische Aufarbeitung der
Novemberpogrome und das Holocaust wird
stets auch die Fragen von Schuld und
Verantwortung auf die Auseinandersetzung
mit diesem Teil unserer Vergangenheit
ist und bleibt schmerzhaft aber auch
unabdingbar
die Frage nach der historischen
Verantwortung ist für jede Generation
die nach dem Ende des Zweiten Weltkriegs
in Deutschland geboren wurde eine sich
immer wieder aufs Neue stellen der
Herausforderung
umso wichtiger ist es bewussten Raum für
die Präsenz jüdischen Lebens in
Deutschland zu schaffen
bis heute ist jüdisches Leben in
Deutschland bedroht der Hass auf
Jüdinnen und Juden nimmt vielerorts zu
dies bestätigen leider auch die Zahlen
des Bundeskriminalamtes für
antisemitisch motivierte Straftaten
nur wenige Straßenzüge von hier steht
die Synagoge der jüdischen Gemeinde
Berlins unter anderem den Polizeischutz
und auch an der Braunschweiger
Braunschweiger Synagoge kann zum
heutigen Gedenken an die Reichsburg
Ohmacht die Kranzniederlegung wieder
nicht ohne Gegenwart eines
Streifenwagens stattfinden
ich wünsche mir sehr das jüdisches Leben
84 Jahre nach den furchtbaren vollfällen
der Reichspogromnacht Raum im
öffentlichen Leben in Deutschland findet
ich wünsche mir dass die Präsenz
jüdischen lebenszonale maalität und zur
Pluralität unseres Alltags in der
Bundesrepublik gehört das ist möglich
ist ohne Angst und Hass
selbstverständlich jüdisches Leben und
privaten und öffentlichen Raum in
Kreuzstein zu praktizieren und zu leben
die bewusste Auseinandersetzung mit der
Vergangenheit das Pflegen von
Erinnerungskulturen wie sie zum Beispiel
durch das Landesmuseum Braunschweig aber
auch an vielen anderen Orten praktiziert
wird schafft so hoffe ich weiterhin die
Grundlage für die Entfaltung jüdischen
Lebens in Deutschland wir brauchen ein
sensiblen Umgang mit unserer
Erinnerungskultur im Inneren wie auch im
Ausland das verdeutlichte
das war deutlich da auch eine für diese
Woche geplante Veranstaltung des
Goethe-Instituts in Kooperation mit der
Rosa-Luxemburg-Stiftung in Tel Aviv
meine Kolleginnen dateberg hat es auch
angesprochen es ist unsere Pflicht als
Menschen nicht wegzusehen wenn jüdischem
Leben in Deutschland das Existenzrecht
abgesprochen wird es ist unsere Pflicht
Räume zu schaffen und zu bewahren in
denen die Erinnerungen an jüdische
Kultur in Deutschland bewusst gepflegt
unterhalten wird wir brauchen auch für
zukünftige Generationen die noch vor dem
schwierigen Auseinandersetzung mit den
Erinnerungen an die progrome und den
Holocaust stehen kollektive
Anknüpfungspunkte und Orte in Form von
Museen Synagogen vor allem aber auch
Menschen die das Erinnern nicht
vergessen
wir müssen Orte der Erinnerung schaffen
und erhalten denn handeln im Hier und
Jetzt das Einstehen für Präsenz
jüdischen Lebens im öffentlichen Raum
setzt Bewusstsein um das Geschehene
voraus und um die historische
Verantwortung die damit einhergeht denn
ganz im Sinne dieser Debatte meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren erinnern
heißt handeln das heißt
Erinnerungskultur bewussten pflegen es
heißt Raum für dieses Leben in
Deutschland zu schaffen das heißt
nachfragt wenn es unangenehm ist und es
heißt nicht wegsehen wenn seine Existenz
bedroht wird herzlichen Dank für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
aber nächste Rednerin ist die Kollegin
Simona Kos SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren am 9 November
1938 eine Mittwoch wie heute rotteten
sich um diese Uhrzeit die horndera
zusammen die nur wenige Stunden später
Synagogen anzündeten und abbrennen
ließen Geschäfte und Wohnungen von
Jüdinnen und Juden zerstörten und
Menschen misshandelten verhafteten auf
sie einschlugen und töteten nur ja nur
weil sie Juden waren und den
Nationalsozialisten als billiges
Feindbild als Sündenbock dienten
die Reichspogromnacht steht für eine der
schrecklichsten
antisemitischen Gewalttaten gerade weil
sie im Vorfeld wohlorganisiert dem
Volkszorn simulierte und anstachelte
es sollte in dieser Nacht deutlich
werden dass die Nazis mit ihren
Massenverhaftungen mit Sondergesetzen
und Demütigungen im Sinne der
Bevölkerung handelten die angeblich noch
härteres Vorgehen gegen Jüdinnen und
Juden verlangten
auf diese Nacht folgten in noch größerem
Umfang Vertreibung Verschleppung und
letztlich die Ermordung von 6 Millionen
Menschen in den vernichtungslagerern nur
ja nur weil diese Menschen Juden waren
die Nationalsozialisten knüpften für er
schreckliches Handeln an tief geprägte
Vorurteile an
Judenhass und Judenfeindlichkeit waren
längst salonfähig
so wie der Antisemitismus des 9 November
keineswegs spontan war so hat er leider
keineswegs mit dem Jahr 1945 aufgehört
zu existieren ganz im Gegenteil er ist
da Tag für Tag
glücklicherweise wurden in den
vergangenen Jahren in den Bundesländern
Recherche und Informationsstellen zum
Antisemitismus eingerichtet die RIAS
stellen wir gemeinsam meine Damen und
Herren sollten diese Stellen weiter
unterstützen und verstetigen nach den
Zahlen im Bericht von RIAS wurden im
letzten Jahr
2738 antisemitische Vorfälle verzeichnet
eine schrecklich hohe Zahl
leider müssen wir von einer noch höheren
Dunkelziffer ausgehen der RIAS
Jahresbericht liest sich bedrücken in
ihm ist die Rede von Bedrohung
massenzuschriften Hassmails
Sachbeschädigung Angriffen und von sechs
Fällen extremer Gewalt
nicht verzeichnet sind antisemitische
Schimpfwörter der Glaube an die
zionistische Weltverschwörung und
natürlich die Vorsicht und Angst von
Jüdinnen und Juden in unserem Land
sichtbar ihren Glauben zu leben und als
Jüdinnen und Juden erkannt zu werden
ich habe es auch bei uns in Brandenburg
erlebt und sehe es jeden Tag in den
sozialen Netzwerken im Zuge der
corona-proteste aber auch im
Zusammenhang mit dem ukrainekrieg werden
immer wieder
antisemitische Muster bemüht
und wir erleben es auch hier im
Bundestag immer wieder wie dieses Muster
von rechts befördert wird das was damit
geschieht meine Damen und Herren ist
geistige Brandstiftung
dem setzen wir demokratenen und
Demokraten folgendes entgegen der
härtefallfond wird kommen sobald die
Bundesländer einer Beteiligung
zugestimmt haben noch in diesem Jahr
muss das Geld fließen es wird
allerhöchste Zeit für die Hochbetagten
jüdischen Kontingentflüchtlinge ich bin
sehr froh
ich bin sehr froh darüber dass die
Verhandlungen zwischen dem
Bundesfinanzministerium und der
joisch-konferenz erfolgreich verlaufen
sind und wir deutlich gemacht haben dass
wir mit der Bundesregierung der
Verpflichtung den Holocaust überlegenen
gegenüber Nachkommen es ist unsere
Pflicht den Holocaust Überlebenden in
der Ukraine zur Seite zu stehen ebenso
wie den jüdischen Kindern aus
ukrainischen weisenhäusern und allen
geflüchteten ich bin stolz auf diese
Bundesregierung die hier unkompliziert
hilft
meine
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
wir sollten alle eine Vorstellung davon
haben was Judentum in Deutschland
ausmacht jüdisches Leben gehört zu uns
ob in Neukölln in Frankfurt oder in
Bernau lassen sie uns wachsam sein
lassen Sie uns gemeinsam daran arbeiten
unserer historischen Verantwortung
gerecht zu werden lassen Sie uns noch
mehr offen und interessiert aneinander
sein und jüdisches Leben in Deutschland
in seiner Vielfalt mit Interesse und als
Bereicherung betrachten herzlichen Dank
für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
der Appell von Simone Kos hier in der
Debatte wie man Antisemitismus bekämpft
Volker Ulrich spricht nun als nächstes
für die Unionsfraktion
herr Präsident meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren
bereits im Jahr 2019 hat Rabbiner Henry
Brandt gewarnt Zitat der Antisemitismus
zeigt wieder seine Fratze
Hendrik Brandt wurde 1927 in München
geboren
im November 1938 ist der Messer seinen
Eltern nach Israel geflüchtet und konnte
so der Ermordung entkommen er diente als
Soldat in der israelischen Armee wurde
in London zum Rabbiner ausgebildet und
kehrte in das Land seiner Eltern in sein
Land zurück allein das ist eine Gnade er
wurde Vorsitzender der rabbinerkonferenz
bis zuletzt Rabbiner in meiner
Heimatstadt Augsburg und er ist im
Frühjahr diesen Jahres gestorben
er hat gesagt ich bin überzeugt dass das
Gespräch die Konfrontation mit
Unterschieden und Geschichte die beste
Waffe gegen Antisemitismus und Vorteile
ist
Geschichte
die November Pogrome des Jahres 38 haben
in den Abgrund der Shoa in die Ermordung
von Millionen und ihr menschlichung
verwiesen mit all der Verantwortung von
jenen die mitgemacht oder auch nur
weggeschaut haben
wir müssen aber auch die Zeit vor dem 9
November 38 vor Augen haben wie konnte
es dazu kommen
die Antworten sind
es waren
antisemitische verschwörungserzählungen
im Umlauf
Vorteile und Verrohung in der Sprache
gesellschaftliche
Ausgrenzung und Stigmatisierung es ist
nicht wie damals aber die Mechanismen
funktionieren ähnlich deswegen müssen
wir stets wachsam sein unser
Anspruch muss sein
Juden müssen heute ohne Angst leben
können überall
aber ist das stets möglich
wenn Schulen und Kindertagesstätten und
Moscheen Synagogen polizeilich geschützt
werden müssen ist das möglich angesichts
von 3000 antisemitischen Straftaten
die meisten
kommen aus dem
rechtsextremen Spektrum und dazu hätte
ich mir etwas gewünscht von dieser Seite
aber es war nicht absehbar das dazu
etwas kommt
es gibt auch
islamistischen und linksextremistischen
Antisemitismus gar keine Frage und er
beginnt nicht mit strafbaren Handlungen
das wäre eine unzuglässige Verengung
eine geradezu gefährliche Sichtweise wir
dürfen nicht schweigen über
Antisemitismus der sie doch
Verschwörungstheorien durch chatgruppen
frisst und droht die Mitte der
Gesellschaft zu vergiften vermeintliche
Kritik am Start Israel die nur aber als
Deckmantel für Antisemitismus steht auch
kulturelle Vorkommnisse wie dieses Jahr
bei der Dokumente
wir haben Verantwortung zu erinnern die
Verpflichtung besteht in der Aufklärung
aber auch in der Prävention kein Mensch
wird das Antisemit geboren
Menschen werden dazu
wie können wir verhindern dass Menschen
zu Antisemiten werden
eine Frage von Bildungen Aufklärung
Hendrik Brandt hat gesagt von
gemeinsamer Arbeit und Gesprächen
ein versöhnter Ton was für eine Stärke
dieser Mannes
gerade weil Rabbiner Henry Brandt und
immer mehr Zeitzeugen nicht mehr unter
uns sind und sie fehlen liegt es an uns
die Erinnerung zu bewahren
nicht als Ritual
sondern als aufrichtige Mahnung
es gibt keinen Zeitablauf für die
Notwendigkeit des Gedenkens
die Erinnerung an die Opfer endet nie
erinnern
bleibt in diesem Land
jedem stets zumutbar
für ein nie wieder einzutreten
ist eine unerlässliche Pflicht mit dem
Aufruf am 9 November aber mit jedem Tag
unseres politischen Handelns vielen Dank
vielen Dank Herr Kollege
damit kommen wir zur vorletzten Rednerin
in dieser Debatte das ist im Marlene
Schönberger sie ist in ihrer Fraktion
zuständig für die Bekämpfung von
Antisemitismus und setzt sich für die
Förderung jüdischen Lebens in
Deutschland ein demokratischen
Fraktionen von den 200.000 Jüdinnen und
Juden in Deutschland leben ca 70.000
jüdische Seniorinnen unter der
Armutsgrenze darunter viele shower
Überlebende ist ein krasses Versagen der
Politik wenn wir jetzt endlich einen
härtefallvorschaffen dann ist das ein
Anfang doch das kommt spät jüdische
Organisationen kritisieren seit
Jahrzehnten dass der Armut von Juden
Juden nicht begegnet wird und das ist
nur ein Beispiel für die Ignoranz die
jüdische Stimmen in diesem Land erfahren
für die Juden Juden haben Bedenken
Kritik zu äußern oder sogar
Selbstverständliches einzufordern weil
sie Angst haben dass die Politik sie im
Stich lässt
so auch wenn es um Antisemitismus geht
viel zu selten spielt das was Betroffene
berichten dabei eine Rolle mir ist
wichtig dass wir in der heutigen Debatte
ausgeht wir haben diesen Missstand
erkannt und wir wollen daran etwas
ändern
dafür müssen wir bei uns selbst anfangen
wir müssen uns fragen wie können wir der
Kritik und den Anliegen von Juden Juden
mehr Gehör verschaffen wie können wir
politische Räume zu safer spaces auch
für Juden Juden machen wie schaffen wir
es dass wirklich immer klare Kante gegen
Antisemitismus gilt auch dann wenn aus
dem eigenen politischen Lager kommt
eine Umfrage des American Judith Comedy
zeigt dass die Anhängerinnen
demokratischer Parteien keineswegs immun
gegen Antisemitismus sind und der Grünen
wähler:innen sind es 24 Prozent und
unter unionsanhänger:innen 32 Prozent
die der Meinung sind dass die Juden
ihren Status als Opfer der shower zu
ihrem Vorteil nutzen würden bei der SPD
FDP und der Linken sind es sogar noch
höhere Zustimmungswerte mit Abstand die
am höchsten sind sie beim Anhänger in
der AFD und Studien zeigen längst dass
der Antisemitismus zum programmatischen
Kern dieser radikale rechten Partei
gehört ihre Inszenierung als brojüdisch
das ist heuchlerisch und das ist
schädlich
liebe Kolleginnen eine oberflächlich
Anti antisemitische Haltung reicht nicht
aus wir brauchen mehr nämlich eine
dauerhafte Auseinandersetzung und eine
konsequente Positionierung an
Gedenktagen sagen wir ritualisiert nie
wieder und überall höre ich dass kein
Platz für Antisemitismus sei doch seien
wir ehrlich leider gehörte der
Antisemitismus immer zu Deutschland wenn
es bei der antisemitismusbekämpfung bei
Phrasen bleibt dann ist das ein Schlag
ins Gesicht der Betroffenen
dem Antisemitismus konsequent zu
begegnen liebe Kolleginnen das ist
mühsam dass es schmerzhaft das ist
frustrierend und es ist ein Kampf bei
dem wir Juden Juden viel zu lange
alleine gelassen haben wir müssen jeden
Tag daran arbeiten das zu ändern
vielen Dank Frau Kollegin Schönberger
letzter Debatte ist der Kollege
Professor Lars castellucci
vielen Dank sehr geehrter Herr Präsident
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
liebe Gäste wir erinnern heute in dieser
Debatte an die Pogrome vor 84 Jahren
und uns beschäftigt die Frage wie es
dahin kommen konnte und
Teiler von uns ist naiv und wir wissen
es gibt es böse es gibt es Verbrechen es
gibt die Radikalisierung manchmal sogar
von diesem Pult aus
aber die entscheidende Frage an der ich
immer am meisten festhänge ist ich
konnte das alles mitten unter uns
passieren
und das ist doch auch die zentrale Lehre
der Ereignisse vom 9 November 1938 das
eben zu viele zugeschaut haben es zu
viele haben passieren lassen oder aber
sogar manche der Gedanken und
Einstellungen geteilt haben die die
anderen zu den radikalen Taten getrieben
hat
und deswegen möchte ich auch heute sagen
wir haben bei dieser Debatte natürlich
über die Verbrechen die heute in unserem
Land oder in den letzten Jahren unserem
Land passiert sind gesprochen wir haben
den Skandal der Dokumenta besprochen
aber der andere groß ist Skandal den wir
in diesem Land haben das ist der der
jeden Tag in zu vielen Köpfen von
Menschen stattfindet dort wo die
antibiotischen Restaurants und
Stereotype auch heute noch festsitzen wo
20 Prozent der Menschen glauben Jüdinnen
und Juden hätten in diesem Land zu viel
Einfluss auf Wirtschaft und Finanzwesen
oder auf Politik und Medien und deswegen
kann ich nur appellieren der Kampf gegen
Antisemitismus ist kein Kampf alleine
gegen die Täter oder alleine ein Kampf
von zuständigen sondern es ist eine
Aufgabe der wir uns gemeinsam stellen
müssen weil sie in der Mitte der
Gesellschaft angesiedelt sein muss
und verzichten
verzichten können wir auf Bekenntnisse
zur Bekämpfung des Antisemitismus die
sich ihrerseits dieser Stelle Stereotype
bedienen und nur gegen andere Gruppen
richten denn Stereotype Vorurteile oder
sogar verfestigte Einstellung die sich
zu Menschenfeindlichkeit auswachsen die
haben eine gemeinsame Wurzel aus der
auch der Antisemitismus erwächst und dem
müssen wir uns entgegenstellen mit allem
was wir als DemokratInnen und Demokraten
aufzubieten haben
ich will abschließend auch als
religionspolitiker sagen die Religion
wird irgendwie kleiner und weniger an
unserem Land und die Menschen sollen
selber entscheiden wie sie es damit
halten aber wir brauchen auch zur
Bekämpfung des Antisemitismus eine
religiöse Alphabetisierung in diesem
Land die Menschen auch wenn sie mit
Religion für sich nichts am Hut haben
wollen und müssen und brauchen sollen
verstehen können was es mit Religion auf
sich hat und deswegen ist unsere
religionsverfassung die ein kooperatives
Verhältnis zwischen Kirche und Staat
Religion und Staat vorsieht und die auch
eine aktive Förderung von religiösen
Leben in diesem Land vorsieht eine gute
Verfassung und deswegen ist auch der
wichtigste Satz dieser Debatte am
Schluss wir sind froh und dankbar dass
jüdisches Leben in diesem Land wieder
seinen Platz hat und wir werden es
weiter fördern vielen Dank
vielen Dank Herr Kollege damit
schließe ich die Debatte
und rufe auf den Tagesordnungspunkt 6
sowie Zusatzpunkt 1 Beratung des Antrags
zur Fraktion der spd-bündnis 90 die
Grünen und FDP mit dem Titel
Protestbewegung im Iran unterstützen
Druck auf das regimeteran erhöhen sowie
ja also diese Debatte ist nun Ende